pour la première fois de son histoire le
salon de l'agriculture qui ouvrira ses
portes le mois prochain sera interdit
aux volailles et n'y aura ni coque ni
poule ni canard ni pintade c'est ce
qu'on a appris aujourd'hui
motif la grippe aviaire les éleveurs
évidemment sont très déçus mais les
services vétérinaires ont appliqué à la
lettre le principe de précaution
florence madic régis mater inutile de
prendre des forces avant le grand voyage
vers la capitale
ces poulets de luxe resteront enfermés
dans leur poulailler
pourtant avec près de 2000 individus les
volailles de toutes conditions forment
le gros des bataillons envoyé dans la
plus grande ferme de france il existe
dans notre pays trente mille six cents
élevages professionnels en 2004 ils ont
produit 916 millions de volailles le
salon de l'agriculture c'est le grand
rendez vous de l'année
qu'ils soient professionnels ou amateurs
l'éleveur ne comprends pas cette
interdiction
nous leurs amateurs nous avons déjà nous
pratiquons la vaccination nous sommes de
prévenant dans chaque exposition il ya
donc des contrôles vétérinaires en force
et ça va trop loin
tout à fait ça va beaucoup trop loin ce
sont les services vétérinaires du
ministère de l'agriculture qui ont
déclaré les volatiles persona non grata
un arrêté d'octobre dernier interdit
tout rassemblement d'oiseaux vivants
dans les foires marchés ou expositions
une mesure que le directeur du salon est
bien obligé d'accepter
je pense que c'était une mesure de
prévention le risque était quasiment nul
on peut le dire mais les quasiment
nulles pour le montrait nous l'aurons
actuellement la semaine verte de berlin
qui est un gros salon vert culture en
allemagne il ya des volailles d'exposer
la france elle a décidé de pousser très
loin le principe de précaution en guise
de consolation les responsables du salon
de l'agriculture promettent aux
visiteurs de belles pièces de boeuf